voici vimy une circonscription située à
laval qui compte près de cent cinq mille
habitants dont 60 % de francophones et
30% d'allophones en 2011 elle est
devenue orange comme plusieurs autres
mais leur restera tel marcel lachance
avait opté pour les troupes de layton
quatre ans plus tard il est un des six
jours passent et que thomas mulcair
on était restés un peu comme jack layton
beaucoup près beaucoup plus près de la
population
en 2011 le désir de changement avait
convaincu plusieurs électeurs d'aller
vers le npd
certains comptent opté pour cette même
stratégie je vais voter npd pour que les
conservateurs qu'on a une chance
d'enlever les consommateurs les derniers
sondages démontrent une perte de vitesse
des néo démocrates au québec certains
l'attribuent à la position de thomas
mulcair face au niqab
sa réaction face à la condition des
femmes ça m'a un peu contraire et ça a
été jusqu'à ébranler peut-être votre
choix certainement oui comme beaucoup de
femmes au québec seuls les conservateurs
et le bloc québécois sont clairement
contre l'assermentation avec le visage
voilé le lait au duke energy est
tracasse aussi plusieurs citoyens de
vimy directement touchés par ce projet
de pipeline
des fois ici y est dans ses réponses
surtout au niveau de vie pipeline vous
aimerez ce que je sois plus ferme là tu
gilles duceppe a été très clair et
comptent bloquer le projet qu'il juge
non sécuritaires et non rentables celui
que pas changé d'idée
depuis le début de la campagne c'est
gilles toutes les avenues semble donc
encore possible d'en vimy et depuis sa
création elle a également été sous
différentes bannières tout d'abord
libéral puis conservatrice pour un
mandat de 1993 à 2011
elle a été sous la bannière du bloc et
en 2011 elle est passée dans la vague
orange est devenu néo-démocrates sont
tout coincé par les mêmes problèmes
mais je sais pas encore qu'est ce que je
vais faire alors votre humeur du matin
c'est ici à friture radio-canada laval